he said there's an old man dangerous but
I want to get out to the cable car there
are houses in there welcome know what to
expect this is a story about Saudi
people not Saudi politics today we're
going at a very interesting mission up
here in the city of ABBA Saudi Arabia
going to a mountain village and what is
the name of that mountain village you
ask al habala so from what I was just
told there's a there's a cable car up
there that goes up into the mountains so
this is a whole different Saudi Arabia
like it's cool out we're up at like 75 I
think roughly 7,500 feet what's that
twenty to twenty three hundred meters
and the Sun is very strong but the
temperatures are so nice but hold on one
sec I'll show you how I got here where
else to although yes
I think I'm covered
in abba mubarak Ambon but we just rented
a car right yes seven days yes and it's
on thank you guys whoops right hand
thank you thank you [ __ ] out of them and
that was the first tourism visa they've
dealt with that took about an hour so
here it is the wheels the wheels for the
next seven days in the mountainside down
to the seaside what's your name Vasanta
I live up some Nepal
this is gonna be super interesting I
didn't really have expectations to be
honest but it
first impressions are wow it's quite
well developed I mean look at this swamp
you can't really see it tonight but
already the highway is like built out
there are mega shopping malls and what
what's going on here in the southwestern
corner of Saudi Arabia not too far from
Yemen so you know when you're so tired
you start to do stupid things I just was
trying to get into that car over there
for the last couple minutes thinking it
was mine so that's the story right now
I'm going pretty hard in Saudi it's like
there's so much so much stimulation so
much to process so with that said let's
get on it and so in Saudi Arabia you
have to unless you got a lot of time you
have to fly everywhere the distances are
huge if you look at a map this country's
quite big
the inter-country flights worked very
well and then it's a car culture you
very much want to have a car for sure
look at it it's all highways and roads
it was told this is the place to go when
in ABBA because it's an art village I
love doors beautiful door very cool I
don't know about you but I love the
adventure of it all
I just then not knowing is the
interesting part then not knowing and
just well knowing that it will all work
out you know instead of a basic
structure basic outline maybe and then
just you know hit the road crews stop at
random places a few different things
some are interesting some are and you
just never know what to expect it's
almost got a creepy element to it since
actually you know I'm the only human
pounding this pavement the capital
Riyadh Riyadh is very far away
so it almost feels like a different
country my first impressions it's got
like a mm the people look different to a
lot of the people look different well
guys it's probably just as much of a
mystery to you as it is to me seriously
I've been here for quite some time
and I cannot find anybody there's not
one human I am no authority on Saudi
Arabia Dave for I'm probably just as
confused as you are like this right just
like that's a old shitty American car
that you would see you know in a rough
part of say Sacramento California and
what what's going on I haven't seen
these cars really anywhere outside of
North America if you're a curious person
you'll love Saudi Arabia let's just call
it that because if you want to not
really know what's happening and not in
a bad way in a good way if you want to
get into a land of questions and
contradictions place for sure the guy in
the truck in front of me was just parked
on a tree so I came up to him and I
asked him you know where's the downtown
where are the people so he said follow
me
overwhelmingly everyone's been super
friendly
they're [ __ ] everywhere sure but
I've had no bad experiences yet I've
been a little hesitant with saying I'm
American
thank just didn't know what to expect to
be honest
here's an interesting fact a lot of
Saudis have studied in the US so they've
lived over there and a lot have moved
back I met already two guys in this town
at the car rental place that lived in
the US and I asked hey is it cool to say
you know just openly tell everyone and
they're like yeah it's actually a good
thing
they're super curious and very open to
Americans because they haven't really
seen any tourists coming here it's not a
plug for the tourism industry I'm just
saying I don't feel any heat at all for
saying I'm from the US did I share that
I guess this is the market he's talking
about Center City okay cool
what is your name first fine Peter will
come thank you - thank you brother
come thank you it'll come to a TV okay
okay Oh the souk so get clothes and all
that stuff thank you thank you bye bye
here's the market okay awesome
oh honey Regina Yemen Yemen okay I need
a spa yozma okay okay honey la sugar ask
for Hardy Iowa al Sabbagh Yemeni are you
yes / Yemeni where
whoa whoa number one number one yeah I
think so that's a good narcotic
I want to get out to the cable car
before darkness and out to the mountains
here we go on the highway and that's
Saudi for you it's traditional markets
and then a Burger King in highways quite
a few times in this trip where I feel
like I'm in the States I'm in like a
Phoenix suburb
there's the drive-through Starbucks the
big Chevy Suburban there's a family
in a single section so I'm in the wrong
place
[Music]
look at all these monkeys monkeys might
look cute but they're not I remember
once in India a monkey got on my moped
see it eat that thing and wouldn't let
me get on it they're nasty bastards at
least bean counters I've had I don't
know if this is a different species they
have red box though very red buttocks
made it al habala right al habala and
enjoy it and I'll see it can't get them
so the idea
whoa that is amazing
there are houses in there into the
hillside massive cliff here that guy
over there just asked who do I work for
and I've received that question maybe
ten times because they don't understand
tourists can actually come here now so
they think you must be on a you know a
foreign worker so when I tell them I'm a
Taurus or like whoa didn't know that's
happening there's some sad stuff like
like that I can't put the camera on it
it's just like a woman and her child on
the side
so even though it's like the overall
feel I've gotten of Saudi so far as
input it seems pretty well off like you
see the roads are all nice and you know
the infrastructure set up and I haven't
seen really any homeless people but you
do see the occasional at least in my
four days here so far just woman and
child on the side of a store or in the
middle of nowhere like here I think
they're begging I don't know if I can
approach them or not
it's a weird one I don't know the rules
with that like if a woman's in full
cover can I talk to her or not
I just don't know yet let's check it out
so Dom chai so corn and tea up here not
sure what the other wildlife is in these
parts it just seems like an odd place
for monkeys I never knew monkeys lived
in the desert this is how many people
are at the cable car today
what is it today Saturday so I think the
weekend here is Friday and Saturday I
thought there'd be a lot of families and
people out Salaam alaikum
cable car yep oh yeah it's there yeah
Jameel when's the last time you had a
cable car all to yourself now I gotta
find the ticket verse the empty ticket
booth for the empty gondola in the very
empty corner of the globe it's quite
cool out here other than that machine I
hear it's very still very quiet
okay I'm some buzzing and some birds but
you got my boy a ticket
Shukra second time's a charm there we go
okay
[Music]
love this stuff this is travel to me
okay vacation is one thing vacation is
go to Italy to eat the gelato enjoy it
didn't these great for that more travel
is a day like today it's an adventure
it's a proper adventure make look at
this like a Grand Canyon look
okay so what a beautiful place it's you
and me yes just you and me what's up
okay up there I think you said there's
an old man in the house do that door
I'd seen some stories looks like a
restaurant I'm quite hungry
what do you guys think you think there's
anyone here this restaurant seen
happening
in this place [ __ ] is that these monkeys
these monkeys [ __ ] was a monkey can I go
oh okay this is this guy's own he lives
up here alone and I guess he takes takes
care of it
yeah boss boss man Ali okay he's not the
boss at least lost quite a view you got
man jameelah he's from Yemen today I'm
from Yemen Yemen yeah yeah okay yeah me
me
it's here 26 years you like the piece
very peaceful what I learnt in this
journey friendly people wild rugged
landscapes and a lot of adventure
shoot road trip if you haven't seen my
other stuff in Saudi Arabia have all
sorts of videos I'll have a playlist
below check it out things are going on
guys peace